[Music]
[Music]
this dress sucks
i knew i should have worn something else
the dress is perfect
you look great
[Music]
i feel like everyone's looking at us
that's not just a feeling everyone is
looking at us
but most important thing act natural
if anyone speaks to you just smile
so do you want me to act natural or do
you want me to smile
i didn't know you had a sense of humor
only when i'm scared to death
brian i'm delighted you could attend
always a pleasure she come in
i would like you to meet my assistant
elizabeth
i was unaware that american diplomacy
was undertaken with such
disarming charm the pleasure is mine
elizabeth
gentlemen i give you back your host
we'll talk later on that
i'm team zen ryan
[Music]
he hates me the whole time he was
imagining my head on a stick
he found you charming that should be
flattered
yeah i'm gonna shake some hands blend in
find some more quiet
you know what you have to do
ambassador you're a sight for sore eyes
i need to find a quiet place
[Music]
sorry ma'am this area is off limit nbc
personal only
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
keep calm iden
it's okay we can do this
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
elizabeth i see you've escaped from our
mutual friends
a drink perhaps we should get to know
each other better
maybe later as you wish
later it is
[Music]
do
this is fantastic it's not bad
everything okay
no no it's not i'm i'm really nervous
follow the plan and everything will be
fine
just find somewhere to hide and do what
you have to do
right
[Music]
now
[Music]
my
so
all right lydia are you ready
there's a large painting in one of the
rooms upstairs behind it is a safe
the documents we're looking for are
inside
but there are guards in camera so you
have to be careful you got it
hurry up
it hurts like too far away
you know you can't touch other people
when you're controlling someone
this is the place
so
there's got to be a switch somewhere
to move the painting find it i did
[Applause]
[ __ ] the camera was on
the card's coming don't move anything or
you'll sound the alarm
ana film lucha enfie meccano
gotta think there must be another way
so
[Music]
foreign
this is the place i did you know what to
[Applause]
do
crap you gotta distract the guard first
[Applause]
we should be safe
[Music]
now let's see if you can open the safe
good job now we have to read the
documents
make it quick i can't wait much longer
okay now don't move
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sorry i can't do anything to help you
[Music]
uh
jody all right don't touch me
i want to go now right yeah we're
leaving
um
you